l'inquiétude est immense à roissy un
airbus d'air france avec à son bord au
moins 228 personnes dont 216 passagers a
disparu des écrans radars ce matin alors
qu'il survolait l'atlantique
l'appareil assurait la liaison rio de
janeiro paris charles de gaulle
l'airbus a330 devait se poser à 11
heures à roissy commentaire
a roissy il ya moins d'une heure
'l'annonce au terminal 2 de la
disparition du vol af 447 en provenance
du brésil
devient l'avion un a330 avait décollé de
rio de janeiro hier soir vers 19 heures
il se dirigeait vers paris l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle où ils devaient
arriver ce matin vers 11h10 à bord 216
passagers et 12 membres d'équipage
vers 8 heures ce matin heure française
pour une raison inconnue l'avion
disparaît des écrans radar à ce moment
là l'avion avait déjà effectué plus de
sept heures de vol il se trouvait
quelque part au dessus de la mer à
roissy l'inquiétude est grande
l'avion a pu connaître une panne de ce
qu'on appelle le transbondeur une
machine qui émet un signal
mais ce genre de panne est rarissime de
plus la vie on est apparue depuis sur
aucun écran radar à la proche de
l'europe
en clair les autorités s'attendent au
pire pas de point presse pour le moment
sur le site internet d'air france on
indique simplement que l'on est sans
nouvelles du vol af447
les proches des passagers ont été pris
en charge par les cellules médical de
roissy assistés de psychologues
une cellule de crise a parallèlement été
mise en place au ministère des affaires
étrangères que s'est-il passé avec le
vol af 447 un problème technique au
dessus de l'eau des océans juste après
son décollage
aucun aéroport de secours le crash est
inévitable un détournement un attentat
impossible pour l'heure de trancher
le dernier accident grave vécue par la
compagnie air france le crash d'un avion
à toronto au canada le 22 août 2005 les
309 passagers avaient survécu
et bien entendu tout le monde a en
mémoire le crash du concorde le 25
juillet 2000 au décollage de roissy
tous les passagers avaient trouvé la
mort selon les toutes dernières
informations le brésil vient d'entamer
des recherches au large de ses côtes et
on